This is what Japan's leadership looks like.
The ruling party now wants more women at key meetings...
...as long as they don't talk.
The Liberal Democratic Party...
...proposed allowing five female lawmakers to join its nearly...
...all-male board meetings, but only as observers.
Toshihiro Nikai, the party's 82-year-old secretary general,...
...said it's important for women to, quote...
..."understand what kind of political discussions are happening,...
...so it's about letting them take a look."
Outrage ensued.
Social media users decry the LDP proposal as tone-deaf...
...and yet another example of deep-rooted sexism in Japanese society.
Japanese writer Mieko Kawakami tweeted that...
..."Women are treated as second-class citizens forever here in Japan."
Others mocked the idea as a "field trip" for women.
The proposal comes in response to criticism...
...that the LDP's board is dominated by men.
On February 15th, Tomomi Inada, who was Japan's second female defense minister,...
...wrote this letter to Nikai...
...asking for more representation of female lawmakers.
Japan is a democracy without women.
The perception that politics should be done by men...
...still widely exists here in Japan...
...and the perception that good women are those who behave properly...
...and don't push themselves forward also still exists.